con música andina y muchos sentimientos
pobladores de cusco despidieron anoche
al último grupo de indígenas de
diferentes lugares de esta región que
viajarán en bus más de mil cien
kilómetros para participar en las
jornadas de protesta en Lima contra la
presidenta dinablearte pero los
disturbios que se produjeron en esta
región dejan en cuidados intensivos a la
economía de cusco Machu Picchu la
maravillosa ciudad de piedra de los
incas se quedó sin visitantes la llegada
de turistas se redujo de 2000 a 250 por
día según un organismo local mientras
que la empresa de transporte ferroviario
que cubre esa ruta ha sufrido la
cancelación de 60% de sus reservas hasta
marzo según la cámara de turismo de
cusco por cada día de paralización se
dejó de recibir más de 500 mil dólares y
desde que se inició el disgusto social
las pérdidas para el sector que incluye
hoteles restaurantes y guías turísticos
asciende a casi 8 millones de dólares el
organismo también ha revelado que al
menos 20.000 familias que viven del
turismo se encuentran vulnerables al
desempleo hasta el mes de marzo porque
las reservas fueron canceladas en un 90%
en esa línea las agencias de viaje están
perdiendo su inversión y se ven forzadas
a despedir a sus trabajadores para
afrontar esta crisis las autoridades
peruanas anunciaron un crédito de más de
52 millones de dólares para las pequeñas
y medianas empresas turísticas mientras
que al resto del sector dispondrá de más
de 315 millones de dólares pero los
expertos señalan que este 2023 estaría
perdido porque las personas que salen de
vacaciones quieren paz y tranquilidad y
eso es lo que hoy precisamente le falta
al Perú